[Music]
i love creating music
having melodies run through me is an
incredible feeling i just hear what i
hear and i sing it
in the beginning my first album i didn't
know that i was producing mind you like
i'm a teenage girl at this point and i'm
sitting there with grown men going can
you raise the strings here i want to do
just an acapella moment right here and
then we'll bring the beat back in that
is production there's power in that
and
nobody really wanted me to feel powerful
[Music]
we talk about the power of your voice
there can be power
in anything from a whisper
to a scream literally
[Music]
then there's the power of
self-expression and i want to do this
because
this is what i'm feeling in my heart you
said
[Music]
as a singer as a songwriter i've chosen
to be very very specific and real about
certain things keeping things general
but still trying to
reveal a specific emotion that i was
feeling in hopes that other people could
relate to it that stuff really matters
to somebody that listens to lyrics
music saved my life in many many ways if
i can do the same for other people then
that's everything
i'm mariah carey and this is masterclass
[Music]
please tell me you got that
[Music]
[Music]
you